the president and CEO of the Motion
Picture Association of America Jack
Valenti
while we celebrate the arts let's not
fail to recognize the business of film
the art of American movies beguiles and
enchants the world's people with
entertainment that few other countries
can duplicate the economics of our
business equally fascinates the US
Treasury for our filmed return to this
country over four billion dollars
annually in surplus balance of trade so
we salute the filmmakers and the stars
who attract such splendid box office
results and one international favorite
is an extraordinary woman the gifted
five-time Academy Award nominee Glenn
Close
the Academy's recognition of the
ever-widening world of cinema expands
the standards of all film as global
artists bring their vision to our
screens foreign films enrich all our
lives speaking to us in the universal
language of motion pictures as well as
there an own indigenous tongues this
year from four countries the entrance
for best foreign language film are from
Russia close to Eden Nikita Mikhalkov
director from Belgium Dan's Sten
koenings director from France and Oshin
Reggie Vanya director from Germany stonk
Helmut diesel director and the Oscar
goes to France and Oshin Reggie Vanya
well you made my day
what this is something this is Hollywood
uh Eric produced so Indochine and I
directed it have been a movie goers
since the age of 10 so tonight I want to
thank first my friends of Sony classics
Marcy Tom and Michael and especially the
heroes of my use I mean which should
with Merc Gregory Peck
Dorothy Malone Linda Darnell Stewart
Granger and so many because they made me
dream that maybe someday I would be a
movie maker
I'm just curious how many of you are
candidates for mayor hmm interesting
you